tu sais dans quoi tu t'es engagé
pas d'amis
pas de relation amoureuse
ce qu'on fait est trop important quand
les gouvernements échouent le dernier
recours c'est le charter
les agents les mieux entraînés
notre équipe maintient la paix dans un
monde instable
combien au comité d'accueil
dites-moi elle fait de l'humour santé
le cœur est ce qui donne au charter tout
son pouvoir il peut faire s’écrouler les
marchés ou s'écraser un avion tu
contrôle le cœur
tu contrôles le monde
qu'est-ce qui se passe nos systèmes sont
HS on a perdu le cœur
et maintenant tu es à moi
tu es compromise
je ne peux plus me fier à toi je te sors
du circuit Rachel je m'en fiche on sait
pas de quoi ils sont capables faut que
j'arrête tout ça c'est parti excuse-moi
du chemin mignonne
tu crois tout savoir mais le monde va
découvrir la vérité
avec ou sans le cœur
tu m'échapperas pas
les chances de réussir son proches de
zéro
parce que tu as aucune imagination
[Musique]